i'm
tower air force one we are on final
approach
uh
oh
i
but i don't know who i am
another way
hold
oh
the last time we ever
me
is
we are wheeled down
oh
so
my heart's on fire
give me everything i need
the fastest
i hate on everyone
in your heart
in your eyes
you're simply
yes
oh
me
is
so many times it happens too fast
what's the distance
survivors
i would
my
i'll leave
is
true
um
tell your children
in the house
yes
and you are
i
me
she told me
mother always
ladies and gentlemen the 45th
president of the united states donald
j yeah
but there ain't no doubt i love this
land
god bless the
from the um of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains
from detroit down to houston
and new york to their lake
where there's pride in every american
heart
that is
still today
please
today
well hello ice guys thank you very much
wow wow i don't know what happened
something happened this is supposed to
be just a
quick little small gathering uh this is
what's happening
and we call it a peaceful protest that
way you can
you know we're supposed to have 50
people right so we have a little more
and they turned away a lot of people
outside so we'll call it a peaceful
protest that way we can do whatever we
want
you know that's what they call it in new
york in these different places portland
when they're rioting all over the
streets they say it was a peaceful
protest so you can have thousands of
people doing it
we'll do the same thing i'm truly
thrilled to be here with you
the hard-working patriots of wisconsin
thank you
thank you it's a big group of people
this is like a rally it's not supposed
to be a rally we're not supposed to have
a rally
well i hereby grant you a pardon
thank you thank you very much
well i want to thank you thank you in
the months ahead we will
need every ounce of your strength and
drive and patriotism
we're in a fight for the survival of our
nation and civilization itself we are
really in a fight
this is the most important election
we've ever had in my opinion
and i used to say it and i'd say it with
great conviction
2016 but you know what that wasn't
crazy people we were dealing there were
you know on the on the edge
crooked hillary was on the edge she was
on the verge
she became crazy later on when she lost
that's what she began
but these are people that are seriously
radical left
joe biden is nothing but their puppet he
has no clue what's happening
and they're making speeches that are
taped who wants to listen to michelle
obama do a tape speech
no you got to have her get up there
but we're doing a real speech on
thursday next thursday she'll be
listening
doing it live live from the white house
live from the white house so we have we
have plenty to say
so joe biden and the democrats have
pledged to oppose
four trillion dollars of new taxes so
this is a
a group of people that think it's good
to raise everybody's taxes you know in
the old days
a politician would lower taxes right the
great scott walker is here your governor
right
and scott would lower taxes but now the
whole thing i guess it's changed
it's gone inside out now everyone says
we're going to raise your taxes but
republicans are lowering your taxes we
gave you the biggest
tax decrease of the history of our
country and we're going lower
but they're going to massively increase
your regulations in addition to your
taxes
they're going to confiscate the guns of
law-abiding americans they're going to
take away your second amendment
they're going to make america a
sanctuary for criminal aliens they're
going to keep those sanctuary cities
they love sanctuary cities
they're going to protect the criminals
abolish american energy and make us
reliant on foreign nations and force
taxpayers to fund extreme
late term abortion that's what they're
doing
they also want to abolish the suburbs by
allowing far left
washington bureaucrats to force the
construction of low-income housing
projects in every neighborhood
in america that's what they want to do
that's their goal
and we're going to let you preserve your
american dream in the suburbs okay
we ended the program we ended the
program
the voters of wisconsin are very very
spectacular people
we are going to take care of you at
every level we are going to fight for
you
we are going to fight for every single
aspect that you have going
we are never going to forget you you
didn't forget me in the last election
so i want to thank you very much
thank you everybody thank you i want to
thank you very much
it's great so we issued a regulation
and you know we ended that regulation
because when we talk about
suburbs and we talk about other things
we have taken care of about 84
of obama regulations
executive orders you know it's amazing
we knocked out a big portion of what he
did including the uh
wonderful mandate right the individual
mandated obamacare which
totally by the way by far the worst of
all of
obamacare we took it out essentially
that ended
obamacare and then you say
so we knocked out 84 percent of what he
did they say he was a wonderful
president why was he a wonderful
president
if we knocked out and a very popular way
knocked out 84 the voters of wisconsin
face a simple choice
do you want to be ruled by the radical
left mob or do you want to stand tall
as free men and women in the greatest
country on earth and keep it that way
do you want to crush our economy under
the crazy
socialist policies of sleepy joe biden
and his boss kamala harris
and his other boss nancy pelosi she's a
beauty
and his ruler bernie sanders crazy baron
or do you want to quickly rebuild the
strongest economy
in the history of the world which we did
we're gonna have to do it again
we're gonna have to do it again and
we're in the process of doing it
we built the greatest economy on earth
and now we're doing it again you look at
all the numbers we're going to go over
them
do you want to defund and defame and
dismantle the police i don't think so
you want to support the incredible
heroes of law enforcement yes right
you want your friends and family to be
persecuted by the far left wing
it's called cancel culture right
cancel culture or do you want to defend
our history
our heroes our faith our values and our
treasured
american way of life which is what we
have
which is what we have
now don't believe the lies you're going
to hear on tape
most is going to be i wonder is joe
biden taping his speech too because
if he is i think i'll take mine
how do you watch it taped they talk
about a convention how do you watch a
tape speech
i would imagine joe is going to do
everything he can to tape it
i saw them asking him questions today it
was a news conference then he read them
off a teleprompter i don't get it
i don't get it something going on up
there
we can't afford it you know i can tell
you this look from doing this now
we built the greatest economy in the
world we rebuilt our military we gave
you the greatest tax cuts in history
gave you the greatest regulation cuts
we became energy independent we've done
things that nobody thought possible
right nobody thought possible we've done
things that nobody ever thought
you had the greatest year in the history
of your state last year
greatest year and when you look at the
numbers you're going to have an even
greater year next year unless somebody
comes in and quadruples your taxes
in which case it's called the depression
folks it's called a depression
it's not going to happen because we're
going to win
biden is just a trojan horse for
socialism
he is he's a trojan horse he has no clue
but the people around him are tough
and they're smart but we disagree with
them very very strongly they're mean
and they're angry like her by the way
nobody treated
joe biden worse than kamala right
she was worse than pocahontas she was
worse than anybody on stage
nobody treated him worse or with i mean
less respect
she had no respect all of a sudden she's
now saying isn't he wonderful
she didn't feel that way a little while
ago let's talk about her for a second
she left in shame she started at 14 she
left it too she went in the wrong
direction
so if that's if a poll is any any
indication
that's what we want speaking of polls
fake news cnn they probably have their
camera going thank you very much
no no no we have to frankly their
pollster is much better than fox because
fox has never gotten it right fox
holster i don't know who he is but he
hasn't had a clue for about seven years
let me just let me just tell you that
cnn
gave us an increase of 10 or 11 points
in just a short period of time
that we went up and now they call it
margin of error don't believe it
we're way beyond the margin of error
i just got back from texas
and florida and ohio we were all over
the place
we were we went to great states
and every roadway and highway
we had thousands tens of thousands i
would say
at least on each one a hundred thousand
people
from the plane because you know that's
why this isn't a rally this is again
friendly protest
we we're not allowed to do rallies right
because of
rules and regulations which we want to
adhere to but from the plane to
an oil well from the plane to getting
law enforcement all of the sheriffs in
florida gave us their
full endorsement right
and in ohio we went to a plant whirlpool
they were out of business they were
going out of business and now they're a
thriving company
because they were dumping washing
machines and dryers into our country and
i stopped it
and i said you want to do that we're
putting a massive tariff
and all of a sudden whirlpool and
thousands of people they work in ohio
and other places it became a really
terrific company again
and we went there but if you look
if you look at the kind of enthusiasm we
have
we have never had the enthusiasm that we
have right now and that includes 2016.
and i hate to say it and i don't want to
be rude because i would never be rude
but let me just tell you
joe biden has no enthusiasm
no enthusiasm and you don't win without
enthusiasm
like people aren't saying we got to get
him in the only reason they want him in
is they want to stop our great agenda
that's the only reason
that's the only thing he is going and
nobody wins
when you're not on the side of
enthusiasm so we have more
than we ever had in 2016 and in 2016
nobody has ever seen a campaign with
that kind of enthusiasm
and we have much more now
but the socialists will not stop until
they've ransacked america
and laid waste to our cities your eyes
don't lie
look at portland it's been turned into a
war zone and we want to go in and solve
it we saved the courthouse you believe
it
you had to send in homeland security
they were great they easily saved it
after it was pounded portland was
supposed to be watching it but they
weren't so we sent them in
and we will send in the national guard
just like we did in
minnesota you saw what happened there
minneapolis
the national guard went in within 15
minutes the whole thing was over
they should have called him in a week
earlier
my beautiful beautiful fifth avenue in
new york has been looted and pillaged
it was allowed to happen by an
incompetent mayor that doesn't have a
clue
look at what's happened to our diamond
new york was a diamond for the country
look how far it's gone down in chicago
the mayor literally raised up the
drawbridges to prevent hordes of rioters
from
ransacking the city can you believe it
can you believe
17 officers were injured in chicago
they had a week a little while ago
during a weekend spree where 78 people
were shot
and 18 died that's worse than
afghanistan which we're getting out of
that's worse than iraq which we're
almost out of that's worse
than syria which we're out of except we
kept the oil but that's okay we'll have
to talk about that
but this is the future that joe biden
plans to bring
to every city town and suburb in our
nation
and you know for those suburbs i keep
hearing about
suburban women i made the
well you know in one speech recently
i called you suburban housewives and
they all loved it
but what i got they said sir i don't
know if that's politically correct i
said don't worry about it they'll get
over it right
but we saved we saved the suburbs the
suburbs and you know what i'm talking
about
and they said about the rule it's a rule
very strong it's like a law
they said sir we can amend it i said i
don't want it amended no we can really
amend it bring it down
no i don't want it i want it terminated
and we terminated it it's gone
and it'll be reinstituted
joe biden comes in not by him because he
has no idea what the law says or what it
means
but by the people that will be running
our country it will not be him
it will not be him running our country
they will turn
every city into a portland and they
wouldn't mind no one will be safe
in a biden-run america but while i'm
president
the united states will use every tool
and we've done it
by the way our country is doing great we
have the pandemic should have never been
allowed
should have never been allowed to happen
by china
they released it they didn't release it
in china but it came to the united
states and europe 188 all over the world
188 countries all over the world we're
not going to forget it
we're not going to forget it but we're
doing great coming back we're coming
back and our numbers are better than
almost all countries
i will tell you that despite what you
hear look at all of them up there
scott look at all of that fake news it's
unbelievable
unfortunately fox has become fake news
too i don't know what happens to these
people right
do you agree at least the other side you
know where they're coming from
but i'll use every tool at my disposal
to arrest those violators of federal law
and put them behind bars and that's what
we're doing
you know when they were ripping down the
statues our great statues they were
ripping them down
i passed and signed something that's
beautiful it says 10 years in prison if
you knocked out a statue
amazing what happened what happened
scott
i don't see it anymore now they go up
they look at a statue and they say i
don't know
ten years is a long time they say let's
get out of here
but did you notice that three months ago
i signed it they were going to have
thousands of people march on washington
to rip down statues
and these people are sick they're
anarchists they were going to knock down
thomas jefferson george washington
abraham lincoln he was fair game abraham
lincoln
so i said these people are sick they are
troubled individuals they're anarchists
and agitators they're not just
protesters
they call them peaceful protesters your
peaceful protesters on the record
you're peaceful protests
and by the way you're a lot look at this
guy over here look at the size of that
guy
you're a lot tougher than they are just
so you understand that
right look at the size of that neckline
but biden and harris are pro-crime
and anti-cop that's there's no other way
to say it and we're anti-crime
we are pro-cop all the way i've gotten
the endorsement
i got the endorsement pat lynch new york
city police they gave us an endorsement
first time
i think he said i think it's the first
time they've ever done it
that means it's been a long time they
don't do that kind of thing they endorse
me
all the sheriffs in florida endorse me
what you have all of the law enforcement
in texas
endorse me we're getting endorsement
from we haven't found anybody that won't
endorse in law enforcement
we haven't found anybody and if we do i
think they'd probably be in big trouble
i really do
i think they'd be in big trouble because
nobody could figure it out we
are getting the endorsement of law and
these are great people these are great
americans
these are people that want our people to
be safe
so we're thrilled today to be joined by
county sheriffs from across the state
and i'm deeply honored to receive the
endorsement of
more than three dozen wisconsin sheriffs
where are you
wow
thank you fellas hey good looking people
thank you thank you
thank you i like that mask maga
mac i wonder if he supports trump he's
got maggie this big i wonder if he's a
trump
hey thank you sheriff so we appreciate
it good looking guys
good-looking guys
and i'll never let you down sheriffs
i'll never let you down you know that
you know we gave you all of the surplus
equipment we had millions and millions
of dollars
of surplus equipment and obama and biden
didn't want to give it they didn't want
to give it they thought it
looked too militaristic meaning it was a
lot of it was
uh really defensive equipment so that we
can keep our law enforcement safe
and i distributed it all of hundreds of
millions of dollars
it was sitting there drawing dust and
warehouses that we were probably paying
a fortune for all over the country and
you got it we all got it everybody got
it and everybody's happy
as president and as your president i
will always stand with law enforcement
and
that's something that i can't even
imagine anybody saying anything
differently
but this other side does they say it
differently i mean
nobody can even understand it this
november the voters of wisconsin
will not surrender their beloved state
to the left wing mob and that's what
would happen
in 78 days we're going to stop the
radical left we are going to win the
state of wisconsin
and we are going to win four more years
and then after that we'll go for another
four years because
you know what they spite of my campaign
we should get a redo of four years
we caught him spying it can you believe
it did you see the fbi agent
he agreed he's pleading that he forged
documents oh that's that's good no no
wait do you see it's going to be
incredible but they spidered my campaign
they spied on our campaign nobody has
ever seen anything like it
you can call it whatever you want i use
the word treason
they got caught they got caught the same
people
doing speeches on tape tonight they got
caught
so it's too bad so we have some great
friends with us tonight
i want to thank representative glenn
grothman
and jim sensenbrenner is around here
someplace
thank you jim thanks jim these guys are
warriors
also a woman who did so great she was so
great in
michigan she headed up michigan and a
republican hadn't won michigan in many
many
years and we got a lot of car companies
building right now in michigan don't we
ronna mcdaniel
ronna mcdaniel we won michigan
i said get me the woman that kept
calling me in michigan you have to come
one more time sir i said this is it
then i'd leave and she'd call the next
day one more time
but you know she did a great job thank
you very much ron is fantastic
head of the rnc
and the head of the wisconsin republican
party chairman
andrew hitt andrew
how are we doing andrew looking good uh
beautiful kids
good good i'm gonna blame you andrew if
they don't do it
okay i'll fire you so fast then
andrew's done a great job thank you i
think we are looking great here
you know uh we won it last time and you
remember what a big shock wave because
the republican had
wanted for a long time and they were
waiting for pennsylvania and we won
pennsylvania
if we had lost every vote we would have
won but they didn't want to call it it
got later and later or later then
wisconsin came in and then michigan came
in and then pennsylvania came in
by that time we already had north
carolina
you know it's hard for republicans you
have to run the whole board
because they start off now we're going
to play for new york with all of the
crime in new york i'm going to play for
new york
because we did well in new york
we did well in new york but we're going
to play for new york
we're going to play i don't know guess
we'll do a little bit of a tiny shot
maybe in california they like me
and we'll do a tiny little shot in
illinois the other one we're going to do
we're going to go after new jersey we're
going to go after virginia we have a
crazy governor of virginia he doesn't
want you to have guns and he doesn't
mind not only abortion
he doesn't mind execution because after
birth
will decide what to do with the baby
right no no after did you hear this guy
first time i had heard of it scott after
birth
we will decide and we will discuss with
the mother and that's the first time
i've heard of it
this is the guy that likes to pretend
he's michael jackson right with the
dancing
his wife saved him great embarrassment
we have another great friend of mine
a great great politician but really he's
much more than a politician
he's an exceptional human being he is
tough
i had to go against him in those
presidential primaries and i want to
tell you there's nobody tougher
but he basically loves this state i mean
he loves his state
and he should be your governor right now
he should be but
he's an exceptional man scott walker
governor scotland
thank you
i'll tell you one thing he's one of the
most respected men he goes into
washington everybody stands up
they really do respect him a lot and uh
it's really something the next time you
run please don't put marijuana on the
ballot at the same time you're running
you brought out like a million people
that nobody ever knew coming out right
because there was no way but you could
do whatever you want you know that
you're going to be successful what
whatever you want to do thank you very
much god for being
so before the virus came in from china
unemployment in wisconsin had reached
the lowest rate
ever recorded ever recorded
that was part of scott's thing too i
have to give him a little credit there
right
i have to do that but we created 15
000 wisconsin manufacturing jobs
everybody said that would be impossible
121 000 wisconsinites
were lifted out of poverty and 100 000
were lifted off of food stamps because
they had good jobs
and we had created the single greatest
economy in the history of the world our
national economy
was better than any economy that had
ever happened before it
and china was having the worst year they
had
in 67 years not that i want that but we
took in billions of dollars we
nobody ever charged china for doing
anything what the money they took out of
our country for so many years
and the presidents that preceded me
should be ashamed of themselves
for allowing it to happen and that
includes sleepy joe as part of that team
but then we were hit by the virus and i
had to close it up
i took the greatest economy and i closed
it up and we saved millions of lives
as many lives there shouldn't have been
one but what you see today you could
multiply it times 10
or 15 or maybe even 20 it would have
been a horrible it would not have been
sustainable
and now we're bringing it back and we're
bringing it back so
strongly
i took unprecedented action to save the
u.s economy and support
wisconsin families under our paycheck
protection program we helped save over
one million wisconsin jobs earlier this
month
i issued a directive granting emergency
payroll tax relief to every worker
making under one hundred thousand
dollars per year
and this temporary relief will help tens
of millions of american workers and it's
something that people
really i'll tell you the great economist
that's what they wanted the payroll tax
cut
more than any other thing and it really
applies number one they open their
business it's great for them
but really great for you and it's a big
saving it's a lot of money in your
pocket
if republicans win in november we will
forgive
these payments in fall
thanks to my administration's policies
we're now witnessing the fastest econo
and and you've seen this right the
fastest economic
recovery in the history of our country
over the past
three months we have already gained much
more
than 9 million jobs nationwide that's a
record
that's not even close by the way
and you know you heard about the v the v
the famous v and they say well maybe not
a v it's got to be an m
it's got to be an s it's got to be they
have no clue
it's turned out to be a super v because
the numbers are much better when you see
the numbers coming retail spending
has fully recovered and is now at an
all-time
high and auto production has surged 28
percent
and then leaving the great plain right
behind me and we have a lot of
televisions we have televisions and
closets i was saying to another group
we have televisions on floors and
ceilings we have tele you can't escape
it if you want to get away from trump
you can't be in that plane because
the fake news and trump you know they're
going to go out of business when i do
leave
in let's say 16 20 years something like
that so when we live
when we leave they're all out of
business
i wouldn't say that sleepy joe would be
very exciting to cover i don't think a
lot of let's turn on the television
let's watch what biden's saying today
darling
but you know i just noticed on
television that nasdaq
that's a big deal nasdaq hit an all-time
record today the highest
the highest price ever and the others
are right behind it i mean who would
think we have a pandemic i think we're
way on the other side of the pandemic
we're doing great with vaccines and
therapeutics and everything else but
regardless we're doing great with it
but who would think that we hit a record
with nasdaq and the others are right
there if you would have said we're at
28 000 on the dow or just about and if
you would have said nasdaq hit a new
record high
that's great for your 401ks
look you get the wrong person in here
your 401ks wave goodbye to them they'll
be worthless
they'll be worthless right 401ks that's
one of the things a lot of people are
bragging you know
about four months ago they were very
depressed i said don't sell don't sell
don't worry about don't sell
forget about this and most people held
and they're very
very good but husbands come up to me and
wives come up to me and
one wife was saying sir i always thought
my husband was a financial loser a total
loser he was his big good-looking
policeman actually and she said you know
he's never been good with money
but over the years over the last few
years i think he was up
89 i said that's not as good as most
people
he said no no my husband is a financial
genius and this good-looking policeman
looked at me and said thank you sir
because i was abused for a long time
about the way i invested money
and your 401 401ks are great and your
stocks are great
you know when you see these big
companies going up that's everybody
that's everybody the stock market that's
everybody that's just an indication
and they're smart people they know where
it's going you know they have an
instinct that's better than most people
and they see what's happening now with
all of that
we have a headwind and the headwind is
if for any reason we didn't win
that stock market is going to go down
like a rock goes through water i hate to
tell you folks so good looking
if we didn't have if we didn't have that
headwind
your stocks would be even higher right
now even higher so
on election night expect your 401ks and
your socks to go very very high
and i do believe we're going to have a
tremendous success
i do believe
again the most enthusiasm that anybody
has ever seen
in any election is this one the most
enthusiasm
so we got to get out and vote you got to
be careful with your ballots
be careful be careful your absentee
ballot's great you're others you've got
to be very careful or go to vote
just go to vote you know
go to vote we have a little problem here
you have a democrat governor who is uh
will do anything anything to turn things
around
how's tom tiffany doing by the way
another win we just had a nice win right
is tom tom is around here someplace tom
tiffany just had a great win
we're winning a lot we've won a lot of
house seats we're gonna definitely we're
gonna take back the house
as part of our great rebuilding the u.s
military we also signed a 5.5
billion dollar contract to build combat
ships
in marinette wisconsin supporting
thousands of jobs across
we've totally rebuilt our military we've
spent 2.5 trillion dollars all
made in the usa all made in the usa
we have new fighter jets we have new
rockets we've
upgraded our nuclear hope to god we
never have to use it
but nobody's even close it was getting
very tired
getting very tired what we've done with
our military is incredible with tanks
speaking of tanks we left our great tank
i was supposed to close down we have a
tank
factory in lima lima ohio
and it was scheduled to close and i went
to see it i said no way we're closing it
because there's no way
we could ever reproduce that incredible
and
and you know what happened we didn't
close it and we are building
tanks like you wouldn't believe but what
we've done with our military has been
incredible and biden has promised to
slash our defense budget
destroying critical jobs but more
importantly
if we don't have defense everything we
talk about is meaningless we have to
have defense
defense of our country especially when
you look at what's happening
outside of our borders so we have the
greatest right now
when i took it over was totally depleted
it was gone
right now we have the greatest military
we've ever had the greatest equipment by
far
we've ever had
if kamala and biden are ever elected
this recovery will come to a
total shutdown to use their word
permanently
for no scientific reason biden wants to
inflict dramatic
harm on millions of americans with his
basement strategy locking
everyone in their homes you look at
what's happening with some of
and you've got a dose of it right here i
hate to say with some of these democrat
governors they just don't want to open
it up
by the way on november 4th they'll
announce well we've decided to open
november 4th you got to get out to those
polls
i'm serious this is the most dangerous
election we've ever had the most
dangerous
because i don't think we could ever
bring it back if they get in
i don't think there's anything called to
come back it'll be another venezuela i
used to say that lightly
i now say it very strongly because it's
a similar ideology
this will be a large scale very large
scale venezuela
if they win
we're going to win my administration by
contrast
is following the science applying common
sense mitigation
sheltering ver you know this we got a
shelter we got to take care but what do
we really have to do
we have to take care of our elderly
people our elderly people
with heart problems with diabetes
and we're launching operation warp speed
to deliver effective treatments
and ultimately a vaccine and
therapeutics
more than 270 therapies are in clinical
trials can you believe it 270
and you're going to be hearing some very
good news very very soon
now you know we're dealing with the deep
state right
so i'm watching it very closely i don't
need to have them
announced on november 4th ladies and
gentlemen we've found the vaccine
it's perfect i don't need that i don't
need that and hopefully everyone's
looking to do the right thing we want to
get it out
quickly but we're very close both on
therapy
and on therapeutics and on vaccines
advances in treatment have reduced the
fatality rate in adults
by 85 since april think of that
think of that three vaccines are in the
final stage of clinical trials
and we're mass producing doses already
of that vaccine because we think it
works
and we're going to have it out very
quickly we will defeat the china virus
we will have the greatest economy that
we've ever had
next year unless somebody wants to
quadruple your taxes and the crazy
things that they're talking about
we will have next year the single
greatest economy
we've ever had
so biden's been there for 47 years
and he's personally supported every
globalist sellout
of the last half century he voted for
nafta one of the worst trade deals in
history
for the china entry into the world trade
organization
a total catastrophe for korea the korean
deal was horrible we renegotiated it
now it's a really great deal for us one
in four u.s
manufacturing jobs disappeared almost
overnight biden was strongly in favor of
the trans-pacific partnership would have
destroyed our automobile
manufacturing business it would have
been a disaster for our country i ended
it
but i approved the dakota access
pipeline immediately
the keystone pipeline 48 000 uh
of the great rip-offs that was done in
my opinion to hurt our country because
we have so much energy
we're now energy independent was i got
out of this horrible
paris climate accord which was a rip-off
on our country
it would have shipped millions of
american jobs to china while allowing
china to pollute with impunity
and they don't even enter the agreement
until 2030
so we it would have been a disaster so
many things are stacked against us
even in the world trade organization
china
is considered a developing nation
therefore they get tremendous
guess what we don't accept it we've
informed that we don't accept it
and we're not we're not approving any of
those judges
until such time as that ends
so time and again sleepy joe biden put
china first an american last even to a
point where his son
who had absolutely where's hunter has
anyone seen him he's had absolutely no
experience
walked away with one and a half billion
dollars to manage that's millions of
dollars a year
and if you go to the pros of wall street
they'll tell you it's an impossibility
it was a 10-minute meeting he walked
away with one and a half billion from
china
how do you think he's going to do
negotiating biden against
china okay nobody's done what i've done
to
china to russia by the way remember
we were going to be in a war with north
korea what happened to the war
we're getting along kim jong-un we get
along let's see what happens
in the meantime it's almost four years
right remember we were going to be in a
war
look at look at all those people back
that's a lot of people
that's a lot of people look at all the
fake news isn't that incredible
a lot of fake news back there scott
at the end of joe biden's eight years as
vice president nearly two million
americans of prime working age had
dropped out of the workforce
our factories were stolen our country
was doing lousy
he lost nearly 200 000 manufacturing
jobs
he was by the way a disaster on swine
flu
he got a horrible rating in gallup look
at the gallup poll
look at the gallup poll so they call it
h1n1 right do you remember h1 swine flu
h1n1 he calls it n1
h1 but i don't hold him in that one
that's one of the small mistakes
the bigger mistakes is when he says he's
in a different state when he's speaking
great to be in the great state of ohio
but no no no we're not in ohio
you know what you do you know what you
know what you do when that happens you
just walk off because there's nothing
you can do to recover
it's happened to him like what six times
almost every time
that's why he doesn't talk he's shot
he's shot we gotta say look one thing
i've learned
putin president xi of china right
kim jong-un erdogan of turkey
they are world-class chess players
we can't have a guy who's shot and in
his best years
wasn't very good he wasn't very good we
can't have it
these guys are world-class chess players
they're all dreaming they're all
dreaming of joe biden i'll tell you
who's dreaming about him
is iran if we win and when we win we are
going to have a deal with iran
immediately they're just waiting hoping
that biden gets in
hoping john curry is saying oh he should
he by the way
if anybody violated the logan act it was
john kerry
right john kerry not general flynn john
kerry
the cost of health insurance for
american families had skyrocketed under
obama and biden by 4
800 and nearly 11 million more americans
were in food stamps so biden's
abysmal record but you do have to check
swine flu
because that was peanuts compared to
this monster this monster
is the worst thing that's happened in
this world
since 1917 right
where it could have been 100 million
people died swine flu though
look at his ratings in gallup check them
out they gave them
really bad ratings joe bart not that
that matters but that does matter right
you know when a guy is critical
and we've done an incredible job
including among the best numbers
in the world joe biden's abysmal record
of failure and betrayal
ended the day i took the oath of office
we got our people back working
we made real deals with foreign
countries
i told japan i told japan
prime minister abi great guy but i said
prime minister you have to build
places in michigan you have to build
your places in
other countries other other areas of our
country
it's not fair we have a big deficit go
to wisconsin
go to ohio go to these places
he said he's going to do it many many
japanese plants now are being built all
over our country
somebody had to ask him to do it
somebody had to tell them to do it
it's not fair and it was all happening
then it came in now it's going out
watch what's going to happen watch how
good the third quarter is
the third quarter is coming up right
before the election
watch how good scott walker what even
you will be impressed by those numbers
even scott
but we passed massive tax cuts we passed
massive regulation cuts and you know
what you might not feel this
maybe the most important thing i did for
making the economy great
wasn't just the tax cuts it was the
regulation cuts because
the regulation cuts allowed
companies to go out and build projects
that they couldn't get approved for 15
years
and 20 years right
big deal
we replaced probably the worst trade
deal ever
nafta with the brand new usmca
which puts us right at the top and now
canada
and mexico are doing what's right for
our country
it's been a great deal and when the
wisconsin timber industry
was being threatened my administration
took immediate action we imposed tariffs
on dumped foreign goods
and subsidized products saving countless
timber jobs
all across your state and you know
exactly what i'm talking about
you were taken advantage of by stupid
u.s policy canada was taking
advantage of this country not anymore
if biden and the crew get in the radical
left will bring timber
production to a total hall i stood up to
china's decades of trading abuses
and when china targeted our farmers we
provided
28 billion dollars in relief we gave our
farmers
i said to secretary perdue secretary of
agriculture
sonny how much they've targeted our
farmers
how much have they been targeted for sir
two years ago was 12 billion last year
was 16 billion 28 billion total i said
guess what
we're charging tariffs of 28 billion
dollars to china
we charge some much more and we gave 12
billion in 1628
we gave 20 any farmers in here any
farmers
did i do a good job for you please
i don't hear any farmers complaining and
i have
am i right we did a good job i'll tell
you what with a
more typical president i want to be nice
more typical
every farmer would be out of business
right now but we gave 28 billion to the
farmers think of that
and the farmers are doing well and then
we signed a deal with china and i was
very excited because i had a very good
relationship with president xi we signed
a great deal
and they under the deal they would buy
240 billion dollars 50 billion of
farm product and then manufacturing once
the china
flu came in once the china stuff came in
i was not
really i wasn't i couldn't it was
different but i have to tell you
four days ago the corn order right
was the largest corn order in the
history
of ordering corn
it was the biggest china order two days
the biggest order in the history of corn
then they did uh if you look at soybeans
it was the largest soybean order
in history in history and also beef
cattle etc
so it just shows you how smart china is
we sign a deal
and the plague comes in it might have
been a mistake it might have been on
purpose who knows what happened we'll
figure it out
but whatever it was it was no good they
could have stopped it but they know my
attitude i don't like it
i don't like it so a normal country
that's not so smart
in that position scott would have said
oh we don't like the way he's talking
about us
let's immediately shut down he didn't do
that
they said let's order more from the
farmers that we've ever ordered biggest
corn biggest soybean
biggest cattle and now i'm getting my
farmers saying sir
we're starting to like china i said you
know what
we got to be very careful you understand
that so what they've done is they've
gone up they've made
massive orders so think how smart that
is though
99 of people in that position would say
well we're not going to order anymore
they say let's order so much that they
become almost reliant on us
very smart very very smart america has
spent nearly four years
cleaning up the mess we inherited from
joe biden's 47 year worth of disaster
you know it's incredible he's in there
for 47 years he does nothing
now all of a sudden he's going to do all
these things he's going to get
tough on china sure china will own the
united states
if we don't make this deal and we were
going up
if we don't get elected china will own
mark my word well i hope you're not
going to be able to test it out
okay china will china will own the
united states
iran will insist on an even better deal
than they made with obama
they got 150 billion 1.8 billion in cash
green
cash for nothing we got nothing out of
that deal
and i terminated that deal i terminated
and we moved the capital of israel to
jerusalem
that's for the evangelicals
you know it's amazing with that the
evangelicals are more excited
about that than jewish people that's
really
right it's incredible but we did we did
that and golan heights don't forget
golan heights we did go
on highs so we've done a lot in february
biden said
if you elect me your taxes are going to
be raised
they're not going to be cut now that's a
quote how the hell do you do this
that will be only in this state can we
get away with it
but you happen to be right okay you
happen to be right
so i just want to say this this has been
an incredible
experience for me getting to know you
i've been here a lot
we won the state we weren't expected to
win this day
we've been great for each other we've
been great for each other it's really
you know it's a partnership in a sense
but we've been great for each other we
brought a lot of business to the state
we're bringing a lot more business to
the state whether it's the ships or the
crops or any one of so many different
things
especially maybe the trade deal with
canada and mexico because
because of wisconsin and you're
specialized milk
a small subject but the right farmers
got me at the right time and they said
wow you guys are really being taken
advantage of with canada charging you
tariff i bet i think you mostly know
about that but unless you were up here a
lot like i was
you'd never find that out and i worked
with scott and i worked with others and
we solved
all of these problems we solved all of
them scott right
this is the most important election we
ever had
we've got to stop these radical left
maniacs
we've got to win this election
we have many things to do we want to
finish it up
it's no different you plant a tree it
takes a little time to grab on
in addition we have other things we're
going to do more regulation cutting
even more tax cutting we're going to be
doing very substantial tax cuts
because that's an incentive toward
growth and we're going to do it and we
proved to be right
we proved to be 100 right we're not
letting them raise your taxes on you and
destroy
everything that we've done so i just
want to thank
the incredible people of wisconsin
you really are you really are you're a
state
that despite everything everything that
they were saying well wisconsin can't be
won
wisconsin guess what and i think we're
much
we're way far ahead i do believe we're
way far
ahead where we were if you look back
four years i think we have much more
spirit
you see this is easier in a sense now
the virus made it a little bit more
difficult maybe a lot more difficult
because all of a sudden something
happened that nobody ever even thought
about
but we handled it we handled it and we
handled it well and we're now helping
other countries with the ventilators
and other things but the easier part is
i used to come up as a businessman i was
very successful
and i'd say we're going to do this we're
going to do tax cuts we're going to even
space force i never even talked about
spaceflight we did more
somebody said we actually did more than
we promised that's never happened with a
politician before right
we did actually more but i never talked
about space force
and then i got into office i said we
need that because you look at what
china's doing what russia is doing
what others are looking at so we have
space force first time in 78 years
since the air force that that's happened
full scale
so it's great but and you're a big
beneficiary of that
as you know so we have to win the
election
we can't play games get out and vote
do those uh beautiful absentee ballots
or
just make sure your vote gets counted
make sure because the only way
we're going to lose this election is if
the election
is rigged to remember that it's the only
way we're going to lose this election
so we have to be very careful look we
have this is more than this election
that's a big statement the only way
they're going to win
is that way and we can't let that happen
and you know our post office we're going
to make our post office great it's been
a disaster for many years we're going to
take care of the men and women
in the post office and we're going to
make it great
right now it's a laughingstock amazon
and these companies come in
they doubt they drop all of their
packages into the post office
and the post office loses
i mean just hundreds of billions of
dollars
delivering these packages let them
delivered or let them pay the right
price
you know so that's it but we're going to
make our post office strong
we're going to make our post office
really strong and really great we're
going to be proud of it again
it lost 78 billion dollars in a short
period of time
over the last 12 or 13 years 78 billion
dollars
we want to make our post office strong
we want to be proud of it
i want to thank you very much you've
been my friends my true friends
we will win and we will make america
great again
thank you thank you very much
and you
foreign
are you listening
but you've got to know this
mca i'm sure
foreign
i felt
my
pick yourself up
listen to me
myself
blue
lady
dancing
now she's in me
always with me
tiny dancing in my
jesus freeze
she
stand
she sings the songs
the word she knows
when i say it softly
slowly
count
is
today
dancing in
in my hands
when i say softly
slowly
on the highway
today
yes
oh
foreign
on fire
give me everything i need
like you know what it means
oh
i get washed away
just as long as i'm here
oh
maybe
the real life is this just
fantasy
open your eyes
look up to the skies
doesn't really matter
me
just begun
cheerios really bad
goodbye everybody
i don't wanna die
galileo
please
oh
me
just
nothing really bad
um
say you save me
you